Alright so, let's learn another tag. This one is the image tag. It looks like
this, IMG, and this is for including images. It has the following structure. The
opening IMG tag. It has an attribute called source, SRC equals, and this equals
the URL. This is the URL of the image to download. Remember, we talked about
how the web service can serve all sorts of different
types of content? If you're going to serve an image, this
is how you would do it. You would include it
in an image tag in HTML, and you reference the
URL. And then there's another attribute called alt. Which stands
for alternate, and this is text that gets displayed when
the image doesn't load. Its required in the sense that
HTML parses will complain at you if it's not there?
Nothing will break, but it's really nice to include it. So
broken requests like if, if, if our browser requested a URL that
doesn't exist, this is the text that gets displayed, and it's also
for blind people. You know, it doesn't take much to add an
alt text that'll make somebody's life or somebody's day at least
mildly easier. And one other thing I'd like to point out here,
is every tag that we've talked about so far has had a
closing tag. Images don't. This is the entire tag. There's no contents
to an image. See? It just ends right here.
This is called a void tag, and a void tag
is a tag that has no content, and because it
has no content, it doesn't need a closing tag. Let's
try this thing out in the browser and see how
it looks in real life. Okay, so here we are
in our little HTML previewer. Let's, let's add an image.
Okay so, we've got our, our image tag, src equals
udacity.com and hipmunk.png. This is our URL of an image that I've prepared
for us. We've got some alt text there. Let's go ahead and click Update. And
ta dah, there's our image. Now, a couple other things we can do. I
can put some text here. There's our text. Images just appear in line with text.
Yeah, so a small image just appears right in the middle of other text.